laughs
I don't normally get visits from former
students
I just I needed to tell you
how sorry I am for um about what
happened
[Music]
all right uh let me just answer that
hello
what
wait slow down
oh my God that's horrible is he
[Music]
we live okay
if someone just assaulted our vice
principal in the parking lot
oh Benson oh my God no what are you what
are you doing instead of what you want
you don't know me
what are you doing this
because Randy I have been watching
you want 20 years old and you are
already more pathetic than every person
in this God forsaken down and that bugs
me
there's something about you there's
something fixable
in there watching me
waiting for me to kill you
I believe
and if I'm gonna help you then I can't
have you getting in my way
because it forces me
to hurt you
[Music]
with me
not against me
I'm doing this for your own good
[Music]
you're Square
we're Square
[Music]